so let's start with the obvious question
who's fired drew oh I think I I don't
think either one is I think you just
have to make fun of make make sure
you're making fun of your target right
and get laughs I don't think there is a
funny or left or right honestly I think
there's a follow me the nut can I just
sort of steal it did you mean who's
funnier to mock or who is funnier at
mocking - mocks let's start with
tomorrow who is more mockable yes I
think the right is more mockable because
they're higher status and you know it's
always more fun to attack the guy on top
and right now the Republicans control
the legislative the executive and the
judicial branch so there's hardly
another game in town the only reason
anyone's attacking the Democrats is
because they're sticking their neck out
for the campaign if there wasn't a
political campaign you wouldn't hear
about the Democrats from politicians
from comedians probably at all because
well they're not puffing themselves up
the well-filled your phone's not working
is a narrative though they're not doing
anything
I do and I'm a Democrat who's sports
President Bush but I only support
President Bush because and I'll tell you
why and I anticipated that response
first of all I think the Democrats are
hysterical I am but really it's not the
Democrats it's sort of the liberal tree
hug whatever you want to call it they
were they're a riot I mean I do a
character on my show named Dean wheeler
who is a real pansy ass when it comes to
first of all I'm a Democrat who believes
that it's okay to own a gun I think it's
in the Constitution that we can in fact
in the world we live today
you're an idiot if you were a
responsible citizen and you don't have a
gun in your home if you are responsible
why is that why is that a boo it's in
the Constitution you may have it you
look at your wife or your daughter being
pistol-whipped in front of your very
eyes you wouldn't reach for a gun this
is a comedy show and I'm going to keep
making it funny here now let's talk
about your wife and daughter getting
pistol-whipped let's reach for a gun I
get a video camera you can reach for a
pop-tart or a drink hey let's sit back
and enjoy this pistol oh gosh I wish I
had a gun right now I wish I'd had the
patience to be a fascist than have a guy
let my wife die I don't want to be a
fascist you're doing a very good job
I can't I'm so tired
whoever's whoever is puffed up in
Democrats who popped a lot of Democrats
and liberals are released like self
righteous and we're here to save you
they have that vibe going that's easy to
make fun of because you can knock them
down really easy and so many Republicans
are like oh we know what's moral and you
don't we're gonna protect you your
family you can knock them down real easy
because they're so [ __ ] comedy it's in
comedy mostly about like attacking you
know the status quo isn't comedy it
basically have a liberality
pistol-whipping the status quo I want to
get back to that yeah well the status
post meeting your wife another you
always want to attack people that are
hire you or think they're hired right so
that that's a lot of live girls and a
lot of conservatives they're better than
everybody else in the country because
they're so paternal and their attitudes
so good I love it has always been this
kind of disorganized resistance to to to
establish power centers
if you go back a few hundred years the
court jester
pulled the Kings beard he didn't go out
and randomly criticize the serfs giving
serfs or sword whipped or anything like
that we maybe really created a society
that's why Dennis Miller I think his
head has had trouble getting a little
traction
what's he gonna do he's gonna go after
the Democrats these guys are so not
empowered when we meet mrs. Carey I
guarantee you comic Goldman
I agree actually what drew said it's
equivalent there's a certain absurdity
inherent in all politics and the closer
you get to any politician you can find
this but little tinge of that insanity
or weirdness that makes it funny and
when you're in the White House you're
the king of the heat you're the most
interesting person to focus on and I
think satire does have that that kind of
interest in challenging those who are
powerful but now that the primaries are
over and we're getting to the the real
thing I think there's gonna be an
elevation of Kerry I think we'll both be
interesting and funny and they're both
easy to make fun of well let's get
specific
what exactly is funny about John Kerry
is it he is a target-rich on fire
Colbert pre comments I mean you picture
he's so stiff you serve picture him
sitting at home wearing a powdered wig
watching c-span I mean he told what you
told one of my colleagues at time that
he actually thought of himself as a
rebel for John Kerry being rebellious as
having red wine with fish
all right you know when he gets elevated
we'll we'll have our shot don't you
think there would be real parity in this
election in that in that sense
John Kerry doesn't stink I mean that is
right there that's mockable he doesn't
stand for a thing he's just he's just
anti-bush which is what the deference is
why I'm which why the Democrats really
you know I'm so ashamed of my party
because it's an anti Bush part it
doesn't stand for a bloody thing
now pistol-whipping the president's war
on English the president's war on
English is occur but the truck carry
makeover you can't beat that
well yeah but you're right Bush did try
to shed his patrician roots you know
what's you know it's great about what
great about what Bush does he makes fun
of his own problem
you know like he doesn't say Night Live
he makes jokes about it all the time and
right away you forgive it right now I
mean no way you forgive it I think
you'll find he's not quite as
self-effacing and a man of the people as
some people might imagine to make a
discipline facing joke about executing
the [ __ ] yeah
Wow sound like they [ __ ] a [ __ ] a
guy off the street and we're gonna shoot
you it's not like they [ __ ] it's the
[ __ ] person had been a bird then he
would have definitely shot let me try to
bring us back sort of to the John
Podesta you were in the White House
during the Clinton wins period where
late-night comedians were having a field
day were you watching were you able to
find humor in this moment I actually
don't think Letterman and Leno had
anything on our 7:45 staff meeting
really in the morning and I watched
Anderson Cooper get himself really in
trouble talking about oral sex yesterday
so I didn't think I'm gonna avoid going
down that path and just leave it to the
imagination but I think that I'd say two
things about it really one is having
humor in the White House loving the
situation made people have the capacity
to actually go do their job because they
could laugh about a little on the inside
but I do think it robbed the president
of something that that you mentioned
with regard to President Bush which is
it robbed him of the ability to use
humor you know you couldn't go from his
grand jury testimony until Leno and stop
joking around about it and so there was
a period probably for a year in which I
think President Clinton had a harder
time actually using humor which he was
so good at during the you know other
parts of his tenure it did take away a
very important tool out of this tool Kim
just had to stop it was it was
impossible for for him to
you know as you say go on any of these
shows and make fun of them so and this
is you know that's what those clips we
just looked at we're all about is these
guys trying to buy themselves some
immunity but for comedians can anything
match the clinton-era in terms of
material okay I think the assassination
of John Kennedy was a gold mine from
there we have civil rights Vietnam Nixon
please we also have Dan Quayle at one
point and that was fairly fresh I'll
tell you you can recycle those Dan
Quayle jokes and that's awesome
obviously it was so funny that Clinton
had a you know a sexual incident and
that that was endlessly entertaining it
and yet all the things that Bush has
done people go here you still have to
respect the office and all that I hear
that all the time
and crowds go oh if you make fun or what
did you do sorry good English aside from
you bring them guns
and everybody's like scared not in
Colorado there's nothing as funny as
pissed
Campbell you are lovely just claim that
having sex as an intern was a joke
Mike Murphy yes you have advised and
worked for natural performers
Schwarzenegger John McCain who could use
humor very successfully you've also
worked for some real stiffs absolutely
so how do you what do you call
governor's senators how do you teach
them to be funny there's actually a true
story once the Senate candidate was
actually doped up for a statewide debate
by the media advisor not me who is
nervous and unbeknownst to the candidate
doped up the water glass on the podium
oh you know it's one of the secrets
ought to die with it no longer in the in
office lost has election no the truth is
the worst thing you can do is take an
unfunny person trying to make them funny
because I'll never be good at and that's
what mistake I think they might make
with care it kind of get them off Easter
Island you know and try to make him
human
it's gonna be hard I think I think Drew
made a good point earlier that the
president is aware that he's awful funny
to a lot of people and and I think he
will do self-deprecating things all the
way through but if you have an unfunny
person you don't try to make them funny
you let them you go sell serious you
know we don't need a clown in the White
House or in the senator and the City
Council whatever you know serious times
demand this boring character but why do
we expect this from our politicians now
it's almost a rite of passage that they
have to go on Leno that they have to do
the Daily Show culture it means
everything there I mean look at Arnold
who would have Oklahoma stand up and
nominate John Claude Van Damme it's
their government yeah there's a bigger
sack I'm saying somebody was behind the
scenes that Arnold thing I went in with
low expectations I was very impressed
with the guy he's somebody who knows
what to underplay is and that always be
underestimated he's been underestimated
all the way to the top of Hollywood have
an unpronounceable name and now to the
largest governorship in the country so I
but I do think pop culture has become so
important in politics that those of us
who have gone out running political
campaigns would much rather go put the
candidate there where there's quick wide
publicity and acceptance that then sit
in the Tim Russert hot seat and they
have to do you know trigonometry on
Sunday morning you know we go there I
think it was just Bush that made it look
like tricking off
all that stuff where is it shadowy
figure took it to another country okay
let me ask you because you have very
definite opinions do you do you think
that that comedy using comedy polarizes
Americans I mean are you in a sense when
you talk to your audience are you
preaching to the choir or are you
probably I mean probably probably all
are if if people come to see you or
people tune you in obviously they feel
or think that we do although you know I
do comedy and then I do commentary and I
do piss off people when I suddenly start
talking about stuff they'd rather hear
me do funny voices you know but it
polarize people no because I I can do a
bit where this character I have a Dean
wheeler who is a this liberal Northern
California imbecile and how many
Democrats think he's a riot cuz they
recognize him you know they really think
that there's a guy like that so if you
can get away with a lot of you just
learn to do voices which may be
something that joint carry can do you
Lincoln yeah unfortunately carry won't
have that opportunity but I didn't hear
that gas escaping like I did the last
time I said pistol whip so if you are
preaching to the choir
if you throw a zinger Adam they will get
kind of upset with you
if it doesn't if they don't recognize it
the only problem very question the only
problem I have with like people are
called so like political comedians is
they're so they count like a woo or an
applause so they get the crowd who say
they're a liberal Danville roomful of
liberals and they go that bushes
[ __ ] and you know and that everybody
goes woo yeah
and then they've got their backstage
they go man I really killed just you
have to be funny that I hear you making
fun of you know and if you you know
you're funny when people that support
the guy to make it fun them can laugh at
so it's you have to be that's the only
rule and it doesn't have to be
polarizing otherwise it is polarizing
we're zip up they're bashing and not
trying to be funny about it and you're
counting noise there's laughter then so
what and the daily show is pretty much
an equal opportunity so we just want to
heal through laughter trying to heal the
rift took the 2000 campaigns which by
the way is a better story than anything
ever could ever be like what's funnier
than Clinton having sex with interns the
2000 campaign it was important to
everyone and no one died Gary let me ask
you because wait I'm ready to shine
you want to take another the whole idea
of being an equal-opportunity satirist
is kind of a contradiction in terms so
that that that sort of person is more
accurately described as a humorist and
that's generally what happens on the on
the late-night shows is that filled as
you say they played one part of the
autumn they play to another and there's
never sense on the part of someone like
Leno that there's ever anything at stake
this is all I'm good fun if you don't
like the joke we'll move on to the next
one
and I think most good satire comes from
a point of view and most of the guys
working in late and I don't actually
have a point which is fine that's what
they do they're entertainers and but if
you if you're shooting a little bit
higher if you're actually trying to
illuminate through satire in some way as
pretentious as that possibly sounds I it
helps if you have a strong point of view
so that as you mow down everything
there's something left standing and we
should point out that you do and have
gotten a lot of mileage out of this
president yeah out of this president oh
sure yeah my business is considered the
gold standard and we would be I've been
running this little contest on the strip
to offering $10,000 for someone to come
forward and and all the the you know the
trolling for trash that that people have
been using to try to establish where
bush was in the summer of 72 I haven't
found any witnesses
but most people some why on earth would
you want to put $10,000 at risk and for
me both basically its I've got cash to
earn that one of these
one of the unintended consequence if you
know part of the lower back of Bush's
campaign - you know this give back to
the grain on needy is that people like
me are now fat cats and I've been just
spraying money out on the whole field
everywhere I mean I must be a ranger you
know century under and but Bush I mean I
would never give even even though so my
interest to to have someone like Bush
when how can you give money to it to an
organization has raised 140 million
dollars
there's the waste and fraud over at the
the committee to re-elect now is
appalling they have spent forty million
dollars and they've only just wheeled
the attack machinery into position this
week so it's it's shocking it's terrible
because we don't do that do we no we
don't we don't steal we don't cheat we
don't lie we don't kill and what I do
God rest his soul
I'm glad were debating Lyndon Johnson
let's you know Woodrow Wilson one thing
that bastard nation god bless Bob Dole
he got nominated with it and then boom
112 not 100 actually John might know a
lot of millions of dollars of this guy
wants to destroy Social Security just
clobber them all summer long beat him to
death I mean it's the way American
politics has played you all love it
because you rewarded every day at the
ballot box but the idea that there's a
Republican attack machine versus the
Democrat one it's ridiculous it's just a
tax worth well we're hoping or at least
better greased well we're seeing we're
just another stupid point here it's that
the Republicans and Democrats all both
sides believe in big government they're
both big government machines pieces the
Democratic Party the only reason why I'm
disillusioned and I'll bring up another
name that we may remember I used to
consider myself a Roosevelt Democrat
meaning we could care about people and
still go ahead and kick some ass now
we're a party of people who just
whatever the Republicans are we're not
but Republicans are including go well
you know you guys are kidding but I'm
telling you
that's why that's why the part of the
Democratic Party is not gonna win in the
fall because we really can't take
anything too seriously with this party
anymore and you got to look at it and
the fact of the matter is we are in a
violent world and I don't know why it is
we we suddenly sort of went out on
certain issues but both sides are big
government sides Republicans believe in
large expenditures with regard to
perhaps military etc the Democrats
believe in large expenditures with
regard to buying votes ie you know
whatever popular program there is for
headstart
we've lost duh do shows and during this
will work for you too do you have if
you're if you're doing political humor
do you have a responsibility do you have
any responsibility all you have to do if
you're doing political humor and you're
charging people for a comedy show you
only you have a responsibility to be
funny I don't want to get any of your
freaking speech you know about that's me
that's me there's a mentioned numerous a
comic is one that gets laughs oh you
murse is one that gets OH
yeah I agree with you and applause you
know when people I can't be a man the
only responsibility is to get laughs if
people laugh at it they know it's true
they acknowledge its you're not throwing
any fire bombs or talk about anything
suddenly doesn't know about if they're
laughing at but how do you deal with
what John said initially which is I
can't remember the percentage of people
who are now getting their news believing
the daily show is news I don't really
believe that statistic because I don't
think they would come watch the show if
they didn't have some idea what the news
was already because they wouldn't get
the joke we don't educate them that much
we assume a certain amount of
information about a subject before we
make the joke and if they didn't watch
the mass media they also would sort of
miss half the joke because half of our
joke is mocking the way the news is
reported not just what the news is so
I'm very skeptical of that statistic
which is thrown around all the time now
because it's on how shots over people
that probably aren't getting you know
aren't gonna want more news and they're
gonna get at the Daily Show anyway I
mean there's a there's a good percentage
of them who aren't gonna go that deep on
the Today Show that I mean The Tonight
Show they used to say that that they
would they could build a joke on the
headline maybe the subhead never the
lead and certainly not in the body of
the story then that it had to be
something you saw passing a newsstand
but you know what was going more
concerned about how many kids can't read
how many people can't name their
congressman or name their senator there
was a watch The Daily Show
I forget the comics name right now but
he said he stood he was a guitar he
wasn't a caregiver you know he had the
whole audience sing the Gilligan's
Island Theme I come on listen and then
he would have had him sing Brady Bunch
yeah and then he would say okay nobody
I'm a Roosevelt person myself except I'm
a Teddy Roosevelt person I believe in
walking softly and hitting people and
pistol-whipping them with the best day
I'd like to go back to something Stephen
said because I have a joke for it the
2000 election was a remarkably funny
event and and for those very reasons and
I was surprised that after that election
hey he didn't invade us to install a
democracy
fools points are also well taken however
inconceivably and irretrievably
misguided and wrong they are the idea
that we're not kicking ass enough is in
itself unbelievably ridiculous since
pass has been kicked all over the world
in the last year I don't know how much
war ass we can change without running
out of money to check out with people
are according they're associated with no
ass kicking the Democrats started every
major big brawny muscular Wars that cost
millions of dollars that required
sacrifices on the part of the country
with these stunt Wars the
spanish-american war the you know
Grenada eat up on and let's go in that's
what Republicans do what you're saying
that's what I'm saying the history of
the last hundred you know ten years has
been as if Republicans go in and beat up
on weaklings and Democrats to learn beat
up yes how did it come to be that well
they're scary in there and we can invade
China
over and over forever saying that
Democrats are wimps and the Democrats
who tax-and-spend or as this this
administration spent more than if God
had this budget he couldn't spend as
much money as these Republicans are
spending and I there was a little thing
called bailing out United Airlines in
New York City it was about how things
become conventional wisdom when you talk
about him a lot example being I think
the Howard Dean's campaign ended because
of one speech in one moment which was
the speech in Iowa that that was then
replayed times that we're gonna be
elected you know you're wrong he had a
bad month
the media [ __ ] that guy was bigger than
he was everybody in Time magazine and
Newsweek thought he was bigger than he
was he was never he was never speaking
for the mainstream okay soon as you got
his ass kicked at Iowa or pistol what
can I allow me right if you're not if
you're not paying close attention to
politics and watching the Returns come
in on cable news during the Iowa or New
Hampshire primaries your only
familiarity with that might have been
the late-night talk shows replaying
Howard Daniels if you're if you're
completely insane on television and
running for president it's okay to get
in trouble for it I think you know the
guy unscrewed his hand on national TV
generously he already watched the
election so then how could the speech if
that the people he'd already lost so
what do you mean that speech did it
people already knew that guys suck well
no you know are you the one bells
already lost one caucus and the Iowa
caucus has never really been that great
of a bellwether and the fact that this
weakness speech did something that
politicians try to do to each other
which is there's there's been a lot of
talk lately about Kerry's got to get out
there with this money because the
Republicans are gonna define him like
they defined Dukakis in 1988 and that's
the one effect I think that late-night
comedy can have on a candidate which
sometimes the opponent of a tennis court
which is to define the person's
personality to define their character
like Al Gore sighing and Lockbox and
I think the way that carries being
described as the service tempt Orient
very dull person is going to be
something that everyone seems to be
picking up on so that's the definition
of his character now and when that
speech got played over and over and over
again and there was no reason for the
news to do it other really than for
comic effect because it would do
anything that that it defined him
whether or not really even whether it
was fair it could have been a single
thing that was not in line with anything
else it did it probably wasn't lying
thanks but if it was anybody isolated it
would have defined Howard Dean a psycho
you could see it in his eyes I wanted to
kick his ass when comics define you and
count when somebody makes fun of you
when somebody makes fun even personally
if somebody ever makes fun of you
they're pointing out a truth that maybe
whether you you want to acknowledge that
truth or not when they point to you and
say hey your hair is black you know they
know but everybody else know they're
telling you that's what everybody laughs
because nobody will laugh at something
if it's not true so he is though two
plus two equal to corn
you can't define a candidate more than
not like they're making up stuff about
Canada it's you know they're just
pointing out something truth no
substance or importance whatsoever right
that was resonating with people they
would have they wouldn't have bet have
abandoned that man the way they did I
mean he got is he just got
pistol-whipped Astrid whatever weight
basic needs defense of course was the
go-to late night television and try to
be funny but it didn't you know he
couldn't put a tourniquet on those
waiting was too late
I mean it's love Urbanek because when
you're kind of a puppy candidate of four
percent you're allowed to be a lunatic
it's interesting yet the twelve percent
think I'm gonna fit it entertaining but
when you become the front-runner went on
a sudden you're on the on-deck circle to
the Oval Office
everything changes about the way you're
viewed and when you when you're when you
are the guy was hot and you get in
trouble and the whole country watches
see how you handle that and you go a
bi-national television it ends it
doesn't know whether that's the first
caucus or the fourth one he had 150
attempts to come back with every keps in
the race I don't know he was over nobody
want to vote for him and all late-night
television does is magnify what's true
whatever the foibles Gary I've got a
great point if I could say Gary you're
absolutely right SATA satire comes from
the point of view and the late-night
guys are just equal opportunity general
kind of you know Leno I have no idea how
that man stands on anything I just know
that whoever's the president he's making
fun of him and you know what I don't
know that that really serves people oh
maybe that's good if you're gonna grab
your news you can see what's funny about
each person but ultimately I think
satyrs are better at highlighting things
specific things about one side or the
other
you don't talk from a place of passion
then you just sound like politicians
themselves right cuz you just tell me
the audience yeah you just tell the
audience what they want to hear anyway
and maybe they'll laugh but the laugh
and the flippant way the drew is talking
about you know jokes like Ted Kennedy
said this stuff gets beaten into the
grid the Clinton thing got beat into the
ground knows that the most like an
unfunny thing going you know after a
while yeah the one bad thing about the
Clinton joke stuff there was all the
same joke over and over nearly come on
and right solution yeah it was like the
bargain bin at Target it's like all
that's the problem of Schwarzenegger and
that was the problem with the first nine
months of Bush is like oh we're gonna
make fun of that he says you Stu Bueller
again it's all personality driven I mean
there's very little comedy that's sort
of because after the media and as a
member of the media I know it's a rich
target you know there's very little
liquor and goes after corporate life and
you know commercialism in things don't
you don't you think the one thing that
is possibly problematic from the
standpoint of late night TV late night
TV ratifies those truths that you were
talking about they ratify but those
truths sometimes can be introduced into
the into the into the conversation
laterally that main
I mean let's face it Al Gore had a lot
of problems but but it wasn't what lying
really wasn't one of them and yet that
became the narrative that became the
narrative an enemy it became easy then
for late night to ratify that to put
another layer on top to say the lies no
I mean if you look at each one of those
stories they got you know get pretty
twisted if you listen to what he said
he's not claiming that he discovered
Love Canal and Sarah Vowell talked about
listen in her book the park
partly cloudy Patriot if you look at
what his speech was what the Washington
Post said about it and then I believe
that was even retraction about the
report that the post had about how he
had said that he had found Love Canal
but it was too late it was too late I
mean no Bush telling huge life well you
know you know from environmental
standpoint Texas is the place to be and
but because his narrative is that he's
stupid everyone says well you know
Saturday night life that which is very
funny where he circle a likable imbecile
in that and that portrait of him but
they skimp they mentioned that he has
this tax cape but you know that's never
the subject for humor at the time but of
course that can't work against the
current narrative so his challenge I
think to do humor in the in the new
narrative the one that's coming forward
in his campaign ads is I think a much
tougher deal unless you know is he gonna
go out and make fun of the price
Halliburton's charging for hamburgers
and in Kuwait you know he just can't get
to it his because his his image not I
don't know whether it mike agrees with
this his image is not one of being
stupid but one of being you know the
father to us all I think that's a harder
place to do humor from actually somebody
said a moment ago that Bush appears
likable that's golden politics because
the average person is not that
interested in going down to the library
and figuring out the intricacies of the
Budget Act or or buying the crap and
Mother Jones like it's true so what
happens instead is they think somebody I
just want to wake you up yeah
so what they do instead is they pick
somebody they like who seems to have
some experience and they trust and I
disagree about Gork nobody to go out of
office because they thought he lied
about the internet I thought it was a
robot that's what they didn't like them
that door is somebody they like somebody
they trust and somebody is a leader can
make a decision and is on their side for
most of the night any of those things
without Dick Cheney's hand up his ass
you know father's political do something
for you on there for a minute
is that kills in about four zip codes
but the other 300 are behind it well I
play all over the world and it kills
everywhere in Los Angeles or Hollywood
were where Greg and I live in or rescue
geyser but I
what's the last person that got elected
with with 50% over 50% of the popular
books so no but you haven't that was
only the people that bothered going vote
this is this was not an attitude that's
reflected in America that's why they got
fooled with Howard Dean that's what they
thought this guy was really something
and he turned out to be nobody cared
nobody wanted to listen to this guy yeah
anybody's president he got John Kerry
one can elect the president for a couple
of reasons one we're gonna look at this
guy
because we're gonna whip this out
they're gonna whip this out in probably
September so that John Kerry stood
before the Senate and called his fellow
soldiers rapists and murderers redefine
redefine because one thing we haven't
talked about is this success and
popularity of conservative talk radio
versus black who hasn't had much success
there and there's a liberal radio
network that's launching well what how
is that gonna work what advice would you
give this listen this idea of looking
versus conservative talk shows is the
most horrific thing that's happened a
radio I don't know how this started well
Limbaugh started it by being a
conservative so then there was this
reaction a liberal ready like what my
life you know
so it's not gonna work they don't have
broadcasters doing a three-hour radio
show Al Franken is a brilliant guy he's
funnier than hell but he's gonna find
doing three hours every bloody day
there's there's more to it so it's if
they got to get away from this idea of
conservative versus liberal talk-show
host they have to start to just as a
person I say try when there's the first
amendment it might work to spend all
your money on it sell the hybrid cars
well put it all into the radio network
take your best shot
it is it isn't trifle absurd to start a
liberal radio network at this late date
not that radio is of course the most
all-encompassing media I was thinking a
liberal Pony Express might be more
effective or maybe a liberal carrier
pigeon that can go and disseminate the
good news going back to the initial
initial premise of this debate is who's
funnier the right of the left the fact
that Rush Limbaugh is considered
humorous by conservatives absolutely
defines that the left as always is to
call women feminazis and the rail about
Hillary cutting way after the sell-by
date then that's not that going back to
Gary's point a satirist has to have a
point of view otherwise they are a bland
late-night talk show host who plays all
sides against the middle if you don't
have a point of view then what are you
talking about don't you need a certain
amount of anger to drive talk radio and
liberals liberals who heretofore had
sort of an NPR conversational tone now
have you know books like scumbag the
lives of Laura Bush
liberals have discovered their there is
so why why doesn't this make it a good
power Danielle and now you know the
Volvo has turned times like completely
missed the point of how radio works
radio is just you know it is an
entertainment medium and to say uh-huh
that's like guys Rush Limbaugh's is a
conservative so therefore we have to
have liberals is he is an entertaining
guy what he want to call the humorist
assess whatever he's entertaining
awfully and the guy like what's funnier
than the caller abortion which I thought
was pretty good
he also you know made fun of the
homeless he also he did it at a time
when nobody was doing it and it made it
really different frankly let me get back
to the point you are making why do both
sides
CBS New York Times why do both sides
always feel like the mainstream media is
misrepresenting them but now I actually
temperate that I find generally the
media makes a lot of mistakes and
confidence divinity PAC journalism chief
applause you know all the usual kind of
problems I don't think it's as much of a
bias ideologically as people on the
right often thing I think most people
who work in the liberal media are pretty
aren't working the media are pretty
liberal but I don't think they wake up
every day for partisan bias I think more
they just don't get like the flyover
States I mean I
you could you could do the
million-dollar prize walking in the New
York Times newsroom and find a pro-lifer
now you know 40-some depending on how
you want to debate the polling percent
of America or bro life I guarantee
they're pretty hard to find in the media
elite so I think it's more of a cultural
disconnect than a big partisan liberal
bias
instead the farther you get out of the
cranky side of either left-to-right am
in few sentences here he'd rant and rave
about how his gasoline pill geodesic
dome plan have been totally covered up
by the media and if only people would
hear and he'd win
Nader would go on for hours about this
stuff so would Pat Buchanan so I think
the more you are in the cranky side of
the horseshoe the anger you get about
the media but fundamentally the problem
is much more packed journalism and
incompetence Don well you know I think
that I wanted to come back to the radio
thing because I think that most of
conservative talk radio is characterized
by people who are angry and who I think
they're not funny and they don't pretend
to be funny and they don't really try to
be funny and the interesting thing about
about this new radio network is that
their whole lineup is gonna attempt to
be funny and I think one of the reasons
for that is because conservatives hate
the culture and they're and they're mad
about it and they can't really joke
about it I mean I think if you think
Jerry Falwell well Jerry Falwell is Pat
Roberts City something don't know why
holiday really George falling all I hate
the culture well they yeah they hate
them home they hates abdominals hate the
culture maybe what they they're not
funny they can't laugh about it Jerry
you don't see Jerry Falwell telling
jokes or Pat Robertson cetera I don't
think you know they find no humorous
funny he says sometimes conservative I
guess like I must be funny to gray just
anything that's fun it isn't like he
doesn't like extreme let's serve as
libertarians like the culture they don't
have any problem with hip-hop or cursing
or sex but right
and he's an idiot I mean and the far
left brother left his Ralph Nader a
funny guy I mean it's a real cut-up he's
just a riot so I mean to say that you
know conservatives hate the cultures
like I add Porter walked into my studio
one day because she's a fan of mine so
anyway I slept with her everybody except
brick
liberals hated America yeah and I said
is that about what they do and and it's
not gonna say anything and back off on
it
nothing liberals hate their country it's
ridiculous to say that and I said I'm a
liberal I but I truly believe that I am
because I don't share your foreign
policy views doesn't mean that I'm not
you know not a liberal so I said it's an
absurd thing to say well they do they
hate the country liberals hate America
not only that they've been trying to
destroy America for 60 years it's that's
the kind of thing that has made talk
radio exciting because it is so
polarizing and loud and screechie it's
also unfunny
it's also not creative it's also and if
that's the kind of crap that the liberal
radio network is going to engage in
they're gonna be playing the same game
too conservative radio does and it's
Connecticut's huge range ya know one guy
that gets rating so that's Limbaugh all
those other guys die man
well I don't know how I got I'm not
perceived as a conservative talk shows
cheer grab me and see when you're the
smartest guy on radio tuning accounting
Phil hammer look radio tennis anyway the
only thing I'm trying to say is I think
they do the same thing that
conservatives are doing it's gonna it's
gonna die when people like say Oh
conservatives are Pat Robertson and you
know liberals are whatever bowl of penne
ders tater yeah this is crazy because of
Tomino you know conservative the people
get that really boat and I really call
are just like a shade over and then the
people on left or a shade over and
there's a lot of common ground and to
say like oh it's all pet robbed and even
the cater to people like Pat Robinson
when you when you uh when you think your
appointments up with John Ashcroft like
this great well that's where the people
are about well us people vote too but
those are the people make the noise
during the primaries and people that
those are the people buffer in the third
the primaries and maybe also people to
call in but people who vote are people
right in the middle on one side of the
other that have other concerns besides
that far deserves any time it's a
mistake Decatur don't yeah one of the
problems we've got can weigh the
distribution system of politics word
primaries few people show up to vote on
either side so the more ideological
needs side can dominate well being left
with the Dems and and some of our
Roberts tonight's on the Republican side
though the truth is our Robertson is so
interesting is kind of a threatening
cloud he's overwritten there's somebody
with a lot of influence he doesn't
really have a party not like he used it
we have a few minutes left and I wanted
do you have a point well he was saying
yeah Robert in the story about two weeks
ago whatever we're trying to period
never mind it's a joke
pat robertson said God told him wish was
gonna win the next election and I have
trouble believing that God takes Pat's
calls on a regular and I agree with what
you said Phil that's Ann Coulter says
things like liberals hate American it's
those weird blanket statements but it
goes back to what you said about Kerry
in the beginning that's why it's anybody
but Bush at this point we're willing to
accept the carries of flim-flam in order
to just eject bush out of office because
I'm so tired of hearing I know there
need to be dangerously getting close to
politics as opposed to humor group shots
the red raker I think it's unfortunate
let's take some questions from the
audience for a couple of minutes I see a
hand but there's their microphone use
voter turnout has gone down since Ron
all right folks good for rock the boats
good if you're a college and you want to
get laid and you want to press the girl
about how smart you are politically do
you think it'll rock the boat
so maybe our opinion doesn't cover the
entire water-salt weapons I don't think
on that side I own I own four guns I'm
two rifles and two handguns
I bought the rifles because they were
trying the government decided to ban
them I thought wow before the government
ban something I just want to buy
and I think I think assault weapons is a
misnomer and every weapon is an assault
weapon a rock is an assault weapon but
no you don't need full auto with a team
I'll clip to go hunting you said we
don't need it for home defense either I
got like that why the white-tailed deer
is overrun Indiana right the NRA has
been so vilified because by but if you
can't admit I think the NRA would have
no well they shouldn't have I feel crazy
I have no problem with gun locks I think
people that if you have a kid in your
home and you don't have your clip empty
in a separate place from your gun or you
know you know where it is but you you
have to be really really safe about
these things and they're not taught I
never bring my guns out to my friends
about any look am I good I just locked
up and a safe or nobody can get to
accept me when I need to if I need to
and if you if you're safe about it and
have a brain there's nothing wrong with
having um she's not looking that bad get
back to see is Godsey
learn about drew let's go riding we were
all your political fooling around do you
ever find yourself in grave danger and
if so what do you plan to do about it
some people on the road I'm afraid
they'll punch me I get death threats on
a regular basis really everybody they
travel the breaks house and what I do
know I look at this postmark it always
says Santa Clarita now I walk to my car
at night in a garage that you know by
myself and if a guy wants to kill me
he's gonna do it so I think anybody that
sends you death threats is not serious
just continue to be funny if they're
making jokes and trying to be
entertaining and not you know I think
one of the things that people on the
Left got in trouble with when they were
protesting the the latest war in Iraq
was that they at the moment at which
these entertainers should have used what
they do best which is entertained they
stopped and they said no I want to make
a political statement they never
vilified and you know ostracized by the
general public because of that and
there's nothing wrong with making a
political statement but if you've got to
do with what you do best
well you know you got to continue to be
funny you stay another medium yeah
go with what you know you can't just say
it's wrong I have a right to say it's
wrong yes but son pens dispatches from
Baghdad I'm sure you know son I mean the
mainstream media tries to be able to go
in and so I think in the you know
seventy years ago when you lived in any
American city and you had eight
newspapers for them decidedly to the
left for them to the right you know you
could pick and choose the media you
wanted and you know I think that was in
many ways sort of a more fruitful era
and you know I sort of hope that the the
rise of Fox News sort of gives rise to
you know liberal networks i'ma like and
Anna I think one ought to be able to
pick and choose their news I have a
question sort of directly for Phil but I
hope it stimulates some conversation
here which is how do you reconcile being
a liberal who supports Bush when he's
speaking out about trying to create an
amendment in the Constitution is really
there I just agree with the president I
greet brownies for I'm for you guys to
be I think that the admit the gay
amendment would be the first time in the
history of our country we've passed an
amendment to limits or or keep a right
away from prohibition was give all of us
you know sort of suffered under
prohibition let's say that figuratively
I wasn't around but to say you people
there you don't get to do with the rest
of us that's the first time in the
history of our country we would ever do
that and that's a that's a black day and
I would I would I president boys have
you met me
again I don't think he's that I don't
think he's an evil and evil enough man
to actually do that I just don't think
it will pass a suppressive amendment
this country it's incredibly hard to get
an amendment to the Constitution you
have to have the state's ratify or says
he's making pandering to that far right
and then he's it's the thing where he
find a politician do it all the time
they they say hey I'm for this thing for
the one day to get the press conference
and then they drop it they don't
campaign wasn't the only clear on the
run is a career advocated three or four
five different amendments I mean it's
just flag burning option is their way of
saying I'm really serious about this I'm
willing to tear up the Constitution
that's how seriously do you support no I
don't believe in federalizing family law
but I know that's the same argument they
were giving at the time of civil rights
well it's been leave on the state level
that's dangerous too you can't leave
those kinds of things to this stage but
straight people have done such a great
job
Kobe Bryant Robert Blake owed us that
marriage counseling program is getting
placed before the Britney Spears
situation so how come Kerry is against
gay marriage II know that's gotta hurt
how come yeah it's weak and vacillating
let's take one question we they're gonna
make us leave the room watching the room
watching a bunch of rich middle-aged
white guys have this discussion on stage
may lend to my actually not a question
but a proposition that I sitting
watching listening today it's been a
tremendous amount of fun but I might
suggest that we start a national
conversation about initiating term
limits for humorous and comedians are
the term limit that people are at if
they want their Congress from that you
don't need to see the term on the lawns
they have elections for that of ratings
to get us out you know term limits uh
which is more powerful comedy or comedy
or politics politics was once asked if
he thought satire had an effect on the
politics of the country he said oh
absolutely the greatest satire of the
20th century was the buy more cabaret
and they really stopped him
on that note thank you all for coming
thank you